ما الذي نعرفه
عنها، نعم، تم تداول هذه الصور على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي اليوم وتظهر عشرات
الرجال الفلسطينيين الذين اعتقلتهم
القوات الإسرائيلية في غزة، ولا نعرف بالضبط
متى أو أين تم التقاط مقاطع الفيديو هذه
على الرغم من أننا حددنا موقع بعضها الجغرافي
مدينة الباهيا شمال شمال غزة
وفيها يمكنك رؤية رجال
معصوبي الأعين ومجردين من ملابسهم
الداخلية ومعتقلين في الشوارع وفي
ظهور المركبات العسكرية أم
ما نعرفه أيضًا أنه في حين أن
بعضهم قد يكون من حماس  من المؤكد أننا
نعلم أنهم ليسوا جميعهم مقاتلين وذلك
لأن CNN تحدثت مع عائلات
وأصحاب العمل لبعض الرجال الذين
تم رصدهم في مقاطع الفيديو هذه، أحد الرجال
هو في الواقع صحفي في العربي الجديد
أه صاحب العمل يقول ذلك أه
تم اعتقاله مع أفراد من
عائلته قريب آخر
لشخص آخر تم رصده قال
إن ذلك الرجل خرج ببساطة من
منزله عندما أمرته
القوات الإسرائيلية بذلك وتم اعتقاله بعد ذلك أه تم
اعتقاله لذا كثرت الأسئلة حول
هذه الفيديوهات  والاعتقال الجماعي
ومعاملة هؤلاء الأفراد
تواصلت CNN مع الجيش الإسرائيلي
للحصول على تعليقات ولم يردوا على
الرغم من أه المتحدث باسم الجيش الإسرائيلي
دانييل هاجاري أه قال
إنهم الجيش الإسرائيلي يحقق ويتحقق من الذي له
علاقات بحماس ومن  لا
أندرسون